so we're heading back to hand air dryers
for this episode of how Geremy is it you
know what's funny these air dryers
actually were put in because we thought
that they would obviously be good for
the environment that we're saving paper
and all that but also we thought they
would be more hygienic in that you would
have less exposure to germs but we've
actually come to see is that these
things blow around the germs so badly in
the bathrooms that they're actually
slowly being removed from
bathrooms okay there still quite a bit
of nasty stuff coming out of that
actually shaking your hands dry gives
you the cleanest hands using soap and
water and then a paper towel is the
second best and then third best is going
on these in terms of most germin when I
say hematoma instead of
bruise a hematoma is a bruise a hematoma
is a tumor of blood a collection of
blood where it's not supposed to be in
Russian it's called
shushka those are some good scapular
retractors
e day two of no PE yeah don't do that
actually I don't think you'll be able to
do that I think you'll like your bladder
will succumb and you'll just urinate on
yourself but don't try to do this it's
not healthy because hydrosis is a thing
where your urine backs up into your
kidneys and actually damages your kidney
y you got a crazy story I was pushed or
slipped I ended up falling into the
train tracks and H in the third rail
next thing I remember I woke up in a
coma 3 weeks later yeah those electrical
Burns are so so dangerous because not
only are they're damaging the uh the
area which you're making contact they're
also potentially Dam damaging the
electrical services within your body
like your heart it has its own natural
electrical conductivity it's not normal
to have body odor or bad breath it
actually totally is in some instances
but this person is going to sell you a
fruit your body is not supposed to be a
graveyard for dead animal body
parts whose body is a graveyard for dead
animal parts we have dead skin cells all
over us and we're technically animals so
we are all walking around with dead
animal body parts on us the idea of why
we smell is partially based on hormones
how much stress we're experiencing what
we're eating what bacteria naturally
live on our skin because they ultimately
eat and consume the sweat and the oils
on our skin and then release a gas we're
sticking glutenous foods like Pizza
Pasta dude what does gluten have
anything to do with with sweat
concentration it's literally made up
this stuff is not natural so what do you
mean it's not natural bread grows in the
ground and whatever is not getting
filtered out through the kidneys it's
going to come out the skin it's going to
come out the armpits it's going to come
out of your tongue what what can we just
universally give science classes to
these people so they can understand how
the Body Works my poop smells
clean dunk
oh don't celebrate
oh lesson learned I'm going to show you
how to clean your fruit and all of the
crap that comes off just how disgusting
it is like water that's it just water
look CDC water just water water all
right I'm going to take my strawberries
and put them in a bowl of cold water
that's it that's it stop stop at the
water eyeball it just okay and then
you're going to do about 1/4 cup of
vinegar I'm going to use apple cider
vinegar but honestly you can use white
vinegar I mean these are all edible
ingredients so like if you want to do
this fine the color of this water is
disgusting the color of the water is the
color of your
vinegar a young man was in a motorcycle
accident and his heart is stopped I need
all doctors to the room now a fire
breathing dragon with a broken knee has
entered the hospital
honestly it's so true like the most
ridiculous things started happening year
in year out I feel like they have Harry
Potter spells on the recent ones
no what is this cat
doing oh and the cat hit her in the face
that's a scratch also did you know kitty
litter can actually be problematic to um
pregnant women Brain Balance Che Brain
Balance
[Music]
checkup
did I did I win it I don't think you did
it I went through med school if you
could take four gummies per day that are
clinically proven to lower your BMI and
shrink your waist in your hips would you
I think people would does that exist no
I am looking for 10 wholesale product
testers this isn't legal though like if
you're going to do a trial you have to
be registered with the government you
have to have an institution Review Board
in place to make sure your trial is
ethical this is just scary oh that's
tough that can make people really
nauseous cuz think about it the blood is
pooling in your head due to gravity and
that can really cause hypertension in
that area I'm surprised people aren't
puking can't see
you those people are the ones I feel bad
for where the gravity's max Nick chub is
not from this planet that's a lot of
weight is that bar supposed to bend I
feel like it's supposed to bend I feel
like that makes it harder cuz you have
to work your stabilizers but that's to 2
three four five six plates and a
25 I can't I can't even comprehend 600
something lbs it's official I'm in full
wedding prep mode so come with me to do
around 20,000 crunches in 30 minutes
20,000 crunches in 30 minutes that's
unheard of I'm I'm trying the M sculpt
Neo today which is supposed to sculpt
and strengthen your core yeah so these
machines are interesting through uh
electromagnetic forces they're able to
stimulate your abdominal muscles so much
so that if you do it for a long period
of time and you go back for multiple
sessions you can actually increase
muscle tone and decrease fat but it's
the same thing as exercising your
abdominal muscles are Contracting so you
can spend thousands of dollars on
multiple sessions or you could just do
the routine and that will undoubtedly be
healthier you're going to get more
benefits you're going to sweat you're
going to uh work through a challenge
you're going to overcome the difficulty
of having to be at the gym these are all
undoubtedly proven benefits look look
I'm going to tell I'm going to tell my
core right now I just hold my core to do
the same thing the machine told her core
to do if I'm getting lit up by
mosquitoes and everyone around me is
like oh it's not that bad I'm like I
must have some sick blood bloode and I
just and then I'm like oh I'm just
better than these people because
mosquitoes want to suck me I I think
about it the other way I think that
there's something wrong WR with me that
the mosquitoes are feeding on me like
I'm a diseased carcass and they're
vultures can a mosquito expert a hepat
what are they called people that are
studying mosquitoes people who study
mosquitoes olist mosquito lists can you
go into the comment section and tell us
what mosquitos are attracted
to
oh that requires a lot of speed oh
oh I feel like the scrotum is at risk
here okay no scrotum at risk oh that
could be really dangerous I mean hitting
your head on one of these wooden slides
would be no joke what if I told you
there was a city where people willingly
paid $81 and $22 for a single smoothie
one of them having beef organ and raw
milk in it I mean look as a doctor I'm
not going to judge your choices I'm just
going to tell you that you're probably
not doing anything revolutionary for
your health and when you're having raw
milk you're potentially exposing
yourself to um bacterias that you don't
need Malibu mango one has Lion's man oh
my go oh if it has Lion's man then you
know you're going to be fierce that day
I mean I'm pretty sure it's a mushroom
ladies and gentlemen the age 40 is real
yes and I don't want you to be alarmed
but I'm in a wheelchair y after the age
of 35 I think it's more about injury
prevention rather than performance now
you can care about performance but
injury prevention has to come
first
terrible feeling and then it takes
forever to recover then you get
recurrent injuries cuz the hamstring
doesn't heal well guys I blew all my
tore my lower abdomen I what his
lower abdomen my abductors abductors are
are the muscles that bring your uh legs
in together what I think I look like
eating gummy vitamins
Wellness Beauty I'm assuming this is a
bold glamour filter energy from within
su su I like sugar those gummy vitamins
are problematic in some ways they've
been tested by consumer reports and
consumer labs and a lot of them have
been found to have inaccurate amounts of
certain nutrients based on what's
written on the label specifically
surrounding vitamin A because they think
that when they make the gummy some of
the vitamin A gets destroyed so they add
extra vitamin A and sometimes not all of
it gets destroyed so you're taking extra
Mega doses of vitamin A and as you
remember Deca dka are fat soluble
vitamins so they can build up in your
fat stores and become really toxic can't
even just pee them out like you can with
the water soluble ones this is a story
of how I lost half of my skull how did
you lose half this all started because I
had a lot of sinus infections and last
year I had five to six of them which
happens quite often and a lot of times
my patients will assume that it's
bacterial sinusitis when in many
instances it's not and antibiotics
actually do more harm than good I was
throwing up a lot and had horrible m
migraines then December 12th my parents
forced me to go and get a CT that's good
advice if you're getting horrible
migraines if you have headaches that
have changed in intensity or quality if
you're waking up with a headache if your
headache gets worse with exertion these
are all red flag symptoms that you
should investigate your headache further
that same night I had my first brain
surgery I had a craniotomy and they
removed my bone and saw that I had
massive amount of staff and sinus
infection so she must have had an
abscess causing pressure exhibiting Mass
Effect meaning from the size of the
abscess was putting pressure on the
brain causing a headache that mass moved
my brain 9 mm to the right there you go
that's called Mass Effect December 23rd
I had to get a surprise craniectomy when
they do the craniectomy they take out
the piece of bone to prevent the area
from building up pressure and swelling
it basically allows that area to swell
without causing damage to the brain cuz
when you're swelling into into an
enclosed space like a skull that's
detrimental that could be lethal in some
cases do it again do it again how so
wait so if you can't do that okay you do
have a higher risk of you know what in
six
years if you can't do that if you sprain
your ankle you have a high likelihood of
dying in six bro what we got to be
responsible with their medical
information CPR CPR no you have to keep
press it press press press uh that's
enough oh my god did they do chest
compressions on a frog there's also been
some weird videos of people doing like
mouth to mouth to pigeons and stuff and
there's really bad infections you can
get like that here's a whole list please
don't do mouth to mouth on
animals okay this is not good for the
vertebrae I feel the cervical vertebrae
the discs the pressure oh my God this is
hard the level of balance here is high
level his semicircular canals are lit
that's the area that keeps balance lady
at Home Depot bought a plastic box to
keep her hair from oh bought a plastic
box to keep her hair it's not a bad idea
to be honest oh
oh that reminds me of that scene of
those people going to run on the snow
and she's like I love running on the
snow cuz it has such good texture it's
good for the joint and then she falls
what are you doing running and you're
saying it was really good oh my God how
funny is this texture for running very
low impact when it's dry snow so your
feet don't get wet I feel bad for this
person because they're not saying it's
not slippery they're just saying that
your feet don't get wet and you get
padding for your joints but I wouldn't
run in snow for exactly this reason I
have a condition called gastroparesis so
gastroparesis is when the peristalsis
which is the muscular contraction that
happens in the smooth muscle of the gut
that actually keeps the food moving
forward actually gets paralyzed it comes
as a result of having another condition
called LISD syndrome and we've covered
Eds on this channel before it's it's a
condition that affects connective tissue
but there are many different types of
EDS so it depends which type you have I
have what's called tpn which is total
parental nutrition and it basically
means that I get fed through my heart
this is my Hickman line it's the line
that feeds me it goes into my skin under
my collarbone and over and into the top
of my heart um it feeds me directly into
my bloodstream that's very interesting
I've actually never treated a patient
with this type of line before I have uh
fed patients with a gastro feeding tube
where you actually put nutrition in
because the upper portion of their GI
tract is damaged or they're unable to
swallow but I've never fed a patient
directly into a line that goes into the
heart welcome to a day in the life of a
hyperrealistic cake designer I start my
day with coffee cuz I'm a monster until
I've had my coffee or at coffee cake and
then I have to shave cuz I'm a very very
hairy man and so wait that's not oh I
forgot that's a cake messed up my Razor
I'm really
all I've eaten today is cake so I have
my breakfast this is too much cake
there's no way he eats this many cakes
in a day there's no way and if he does
it's
unhealthy getting a massage from a knife
yeah that's what they do in some
countries click here to check that out
and as always stay happy and
[Music]
healthy